a busy weekend for these fishermen as
they work against an impending fishing
ban the Philippines and U.S militaries
are set to hold drills in waters nearby
but they say they've got nothing against
the Americans the real threat to their
livelihoods they say are Chinese vessels
the Chinese are constantly patrolling if
you try to enter the show with small
fishing boats their rubber boats will
chase you away
morale commercial fisherman
is referring to the resource Rich
Scarborough Shoal in the disputed South
China Sea just 120 nautical miles or
about 222 kilometers from where we were
speaking
due to the lack of
kilometers away where they risk
confrontations with Chinese Coast Guard
vessels that control the area
Clips shot in November by morales's crew
show at least three Chinese vessels
blocking the entrance to the lagoon one
of them clearly marked Chinese Coast
Guard
the phone they used was provided to them
by the Philippine Coast Guard which has
been patrolling parts of the South China
Sea within the Philippines exclusive
economic zone more frequently since
president Ferdinand and Marcus Jr took
office we'll always have to involve the
United States Marcus has also agreed to
allow U.S forces access to four more
military bases three of which are close
to Taiwan
a move that prompted China's ambassador
to Manila Juan SI land to quote advise
the Philippine government to oppose
Taiwan Independence if it genuinely
cares about overseas Filipino workers or
ofws in Taiwan remarks that many
Filipinos didn't take lightly the
message of
ambassador Huang because of the
problematic statements that he had
issued which had the effect of
threatening or issuing a warning to the
thousands of ofws currently deployed in
Taiwan it was all smiles however between
President Marcos and Chinese foreign
minister tin Kang when they met in
Manila last Saturday in a statement
after the meeting Marcus said that
recent statements by both countries
might have been misinterpreted and that
Chin's visit was useful to be able to
talk things through
born below Al Jazeera Subic B the
Philippines